what's going on
reject nation Greg Alva here I got back
from Colorado late last night 22 hour
road trip back home boy it took a while
I was tired passed out when I got home
so I'm here today get him back into the
swing of filming again thank you John
for taking care of the channel I was
gone thank you all for supporting John
while I was gone and I have avoided all
social media except for a few except for
some Instagram posting I've avoided all
YouTube Twitter and Facebook stuff and
none of the defenders has gone to ruin
for me I just put out a tweet today
saying what episodes of the defenders
are worth doing a reaction to I can only
use about ten minutes of footage so
which episodes would have about 10
minutes worth that would have a worthy
enough reaction and I'll try to review
as many episodes as I can for sure there
will be a series review for hopefully
this weekend this whole week's just a
lot of catching up and I know John did a
reaction and review to this trailer for
Marvel's The Punisher I love all the
shows from Netflix I even enjoyed Iron
Fist I didn't love it but I even enjoyed
it I've been super amped to watch this
Punisher trailer it's one of the few
things I heard about while I was in
Colorado I did not watch it I've been
waiting to come home watch this so here
we are today people thank you for
letting me do that long-ass intro into
this reaction food
all the things that I've done post more
than it's like John wick
[Music]
[Music]
I [ __ ] love shopping
[Music]
Oh is he intentionally trying to make
that when he was yeah memories there for
you sold your soul too
oh my god this show is gonna be so
violent and ugly
[Music]
that is so cool I want that email a
poster of that
dude oh man I I am so freakin excited
for this I know that when Jon Bernthal
was the Punisher in daredevil season 2
the second I heard he was cast I was
like he's the perfect choice I feel like
a lot of people thought he would be the
perfect choice and sure enough he
freaking delivered on that show for me
he was the best part of that entire
season he stole the show for me
daredevil still my favorite character
out of the entire MCU yes I'm saying
that that's including the movies still
my favorite character yes Frank Castle
in that season he did steal the show for
me in that one I don't know too much
information on what they're doing with
this specific Punisher show I know that
Jon Bernthal did have a statement where
he did say that the Frank Castle that is
in daredevil will not be the same one in
The Punisher but the essence of Frank
Castle will still be there the brutal
damaged tortured soul who's haunted by
his past I'm just super excited for this
because I feel like you know having
these guys the defenders all come
together makes sense Frank Castle I
don't feel would really fit in with
these group I just keep referring to my
chest here I don't think that Frank
Castle would fit in just right now with
the defenders maybe when they do the
defenders again they could have Frank
Castle being there is one of the main
ones but for me the Punisher I feel like
this show won't necessarily be like a
superhero type of chef he doesn't have
superhuman abilities
he's very military tactic I'm kind of
hoping the action sequences I know it's
the really amping up the violence I
heard this shows gonna be incredibly
violent and for the little brief image
we got where he shoots those two people
I'm wondering if the kind of fighting
style with the gun action will be a
little bit like the John wick side which
for me will be fine The Punisher overall
is driven by vengeance which makes the
killing and the crime feel very personal
which makes the brutal stuff feel more
than just flashy gory violence it feels
personal for Frank Castle when he's
annihilating these people you feel it
man you feel and we did get some shots
of him in the military I hope we get to
see a lot more of that history I know
daredevil season 2 hints at a lot more
details of his history in the military
so imagining like the other Netflix
shows of Marvel that we will see
flashbacks and how Frank Castle became
who he is how it led him through this
journey and while I want to see all that
character exploration because that's one
my favorite things about the Netflix
show is the character explorations of
these guys I'm just excited to see Frank
Castle [ __ ] up a lot of people man a pig
is gonna be one gory a show and I cannot
wait The Punisher is finally done right
after three film adaptations that did
not pan out so well I think this will be
the definitive version I cannot would
anyway guys thanks for tuning in playing
a lot of catch-up this week you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell follow us at
patreon.com slash the real rejects help
support the channel by essentially
becoming a part of it over there